Ukrainian President Vladimir zelinski
says Russia has begun what he called the
battle for the Don bass after spending
days regrouping Russian troops now
appear to be engaging in a full-scale
ground offensive along a 500 kilometer
front in Ukraine's east and south after
suffering setbacks around the capital
cave the Kremlin declared its main goal
was the capture of the donbass region in
the East but in his nightly addressed
president zielinski vowed to defend the
territory
we can now state that Russian troops
have begun the battle for the donbus for
which they have been preparing for a
long time a significant part of the
entire Russian army is now concentrated
on this offensive no matter how many
Russian troops are driven there we will
fight we will defend ourselves and we
will do it every day we won't give up
anything Ukrainian
meanwhile the Western city of leviv has
been hit by multiple Russian rocket
attacks missiles destroyed buildings and
killed at least seven people the first
civilian death in the city which is near
the Polish border in the south of the
country Ukrainian troops holding out in
mariopol's enormous as of style steel
plant say they will fight to the end as
Russia claims it's nearing victory in
the besieged Port City
Russian missiles raining down on Ukraine
Russia says it's aiming at military
Targets in a campaign to weaken
Ukrainian defenses
but the strikes also kill civilians in
leviv alone at least seven
the owner of this service station found
four of his employees dead in the ruins
of his shop
I was planning to go to work when my
colleagues called
they told me that there had been an
explosion and that there was a fire
the worst part of course are the victims
I jumped in my car and was here in 10
minutes and I saw it with my own eyes
while attacks in leviv have been rare in
Mario poll they've forever changed the
face of the city Ukraine says at least
21 000 people have been killed here
Paul has undergone extremely heavy
destruction as a result of the rocket
bomb and artillery fire that Russia is
conducting Round the Clock
but the Russian army has failed to seize
mariupole completely all thanks to the
courage of those units both the
Ukrainian armed forces and other
military formations that are there board
those holdouts are making what could be
their last stand here in the vast azov
style industrial Zone with them are
civilians including children encircled
and low on food
they know that if Maria Paul Falls
Russian forces tied up here will be free
to move on to other targets
such as the town of rubijnet now on the
front line and under constant shelling
this woman lives in a nearby Village or
what's left of it she describes what
it's like being in no man's land
we don't even know where the shelling
comes from we wait for it from there
thinking that the Ukrainian Army will
protect us but then it comes from there
they're shelling from all directions
elsewhere in Ukraine's East soldiers
prepare to hold the line against
whatever the Russian army throws at them
our motivation is our home the
motherland we can't take a single step
back we can't Retreat that's the whole
secret of our work
and with Ukraine's president saying
Russia's long-awaited offensive has
begun that work may have entered a
deadly new phase
let's get the latest from a DW
correspondent Matthias Bullinger in the
Ukrainian Capital welcome uh Matthias
what are you hearing about this Russian
assault on the east
yeah the Ukrainian authorities have
established that this was the beginning
of the assault it's mainly coming from
the north from the town of izum that's
uh one town that's in between donbass
and harkov and uh it looks like the aim
would be to move South from there and
then cut off the forces that are east of
that uh and uh yeah we don't know
um uh of course what is going to happen
and how well the Ukrainian Army is
prepared but what we do know is that
they have expected this for a long time
and that they have tried to prepare as
well as possible for uh for for quite a
few weeks now and all this discussion
about heavy Weaponry that we've been
hearing the delivery of new weapons all
this was meant to fight back an assault
on donbass from the Russian side right
and what if Mario Paul we've been
following events there for weeks and
Pentagon says it has seen a
concentration of airstrikes and
artillery there
yeah we know that the last part of the
Ukrainian Army that are still in the
city are in this steel works this
gigantic steel works that was a symbol
of the city and they are staying there
there's a huge bunker underneath a
system of tunnels and civilians are also
hiding there what we've been hearing but
it's unconfirmed is that many of these
civilians are the relatives of these
soldiers because they are afraid that
they might be a target for the Russian
army as well
it seems that the Army is still there in
this very small part of town and it's
heavily bombed we've seen pictures
but for the moment it's as it has been a
war of attrition a very cruel War of
Attrition in mariupo right and and How
likely is it that Ukrainian forces will
be able to defend uh Mario Paul and keep
the Russians out
well the only way to do that would be
another offensive uh from coming from
another side and and this opening uh a
courage uh breaking the blockade of the
city
um we haven't seen any offensive in that
uh direction we haven't seen any
preparations for that so um it seems
that the Ukrainian Army is not able to
do that at the moment
and civilians of course caught up in all
of this how are they dealing with this
increase in hostilities
the Ukrainian authorities have called
upon civilians to leave these areas in
donbass that are likely to be uh the
theater of the next uh escalation
um we have also seen that there were
trains to bring out people we don't know
how many civilians are left there but
from what we've seen in the war before
what we've seen in mariopol and north of
Kiev is that this is a war that spares
no one and that it's it's it can be
extremely uh cruel on civilians as well
so
um most people would probably be well
advised to follow this uh this advice by
the government okay thank you for that
Matthias in Kiev
foreign
bass has seen many people in other
war-torn parts of Ukraine returned to
their homes or what's left of them DW
correspondent Rebecca Ritter's traveled
to the city of European where residents
have started to rebuild despite the
constant fear that the calm may not last
one thing that strikes you when you
enter a peen is the silence
these once bustling streets now scorched
and deserted
then sometimes the silence is broken
by the sound of people trying to put
their lives back together
around 300 square meters of roof is
missing above four of the apartments
there's nothing but the blue sky above
Olga is the caretaker of these 82 flats
and she lives in one up the top
my apartment is in this part of the
building that was damaged by missiles
she stayed right through the occupation
to try to save them from Russian
soldiers taking them over
but was helpless to stop the missiles
for now it is in this state the house is
uninhabitable until we rebuild it
next door to Olga another group with a
similar story they tell me this wasn't
the first time they've had to flee one
of Putin's Wars
many live here as a last resort do you
understand many of us are from dunbas we
came here from war just to Simply live
and war came here after us we are
peaceful people we don't want anything
bad we just want to live
the most important thing is that it
doesn't happen again Putin could come
back at any time even tomorrow
their building was also badly damaged by
rocket fire one woman shows me where her
flat used to be
this was my bedroom and there was a
balcony behind it and now there is no
balcony there at all
my things were there like a little Oasis
and now it's gone
foreign
Russian soldiers may have left European
but this is a city that's been left in
Ruins there isn't a building we can see
that doesn't at least bear some scars of
the war and many are ruined Beyond
repair and while the physical cleanup is
underway the emotional scars will take a
lot longer to heal
for many who fled when the war broke out
they have little left to come back to
but for those who stayed behind many
will have an even bigger recovery to
contend with
those
if the war comes again I will survive in
any case I will always survive because I
have a bear and he protects me
[Music]
I still get frightened by every loud
noise I don't know if it will ever go
away but for now that's how I am
The Not So Silent trauma that may live
on in their lives forever